Ronnie's meeting with Caterers this
weekend for The Big Wedding yeah you're
gonna do a tasting gonna taste it yeah
we're doing that [__] tasting thing
Friday imagine the misery on Ronnie's
face no dude I don't mind I don't mind
all the partying [__] it's the whole
ceremony [__] that's what that's the
whole point I mean okay I could do that
in five minutes somewhere I don't have
to do that in front of 200 and something
[__] people that's another thing you
got it worked out you get married
you show up he doesn't want to show any
emotion in front of people he's Mantra
you know no that's just not me it never
was you're a soft guy inside but I know
that you don't have to [__] tell me
that I know that do it for her they'll
ever give her her moment you get up
there and You Go Darling you've given me
the Fountain of Youth the way you look
the way you move this girl has I mean
what young girl looking for you you got
to say honey I hit the jackpot practice
with me we're up there at the [__]
wedding oh dude look at my titties I got
my [__] dress on I look hot look at
my titties look at my titties go ahead
okay don't say that look at these fun
bags they're good yeah
yeah let me see those titties I mean
think about it this is some girl you
found and she all she's asking for is
Ronnie get up in front of my family my
friends and your friends
and tell people why you're with me
let's practice
Ronnie this is the most romantic day of
my life I love you I want to spend the
rest of my life with you you're the man
of my dreams it's only a few years honey
that you got to put up with oh right
away their heart is I think the reason
Ronnie's dreading this wedding and
having to get up in front of everybody
is because he doesn't want to show his
emotional side and I'm saying Ronnie's
kind of trying to admit that dude I
admit that every [__] day God stop
with that it's no big deal This Moment
is about you and Stephanie not anybody
else when Gary remember when Gary got
married yeah we no one laughed harder at
Gary at his wedding than me it was
ridiculous he looked like he looked like
a chimpanzee marrying a beauty queen I
believe the woman was statuesque I think
this is Gary and then Gary goes I love
you man
and we're cracking up but Ronnie we
laughed hard but you know what Gary
didn't care that it was Beauty and the
Beast he declared his love for his bride
and you know what had a pretty damn good
marriage raised a beautiful family but
were we all sit and laughing at him
absolutely yeah Robin peed on the floor
Gary I was so proud of you he professed
his love for his bride no matter how
much we made all kind of jokes but
Ronnie Howard's right and and seriously
there's a friend I'm saying this like I
know you you know we we all bust each
other's balls you're the biggest ball
buster in the world you're the head ball
buster here but on that day it's really
it's your day you know you and Stephanie
say but it's Stephanie's day and I you
gotta I know that no but you have to
tune out I know they're laughing at me
behind me [__] them look what I'm doing
we're gonna be laughing very very hard
Ronnie I'm giving you reality oh I know
you you're gonna look like the biggest
douchebag on the planet
it's gonna be jokes going around about
the age difference how you know her
father and mother look younger than you
then to move into like your grammar
we're gonna be ripping you a new [__]
but don't pay attention to that thanks
for the help I appreciate it I'm
preparing you right you know what they
want to do to me that day they told me
and I they told me afterwards because I
knew they were going to [__] a bear I
was looking for everything you know you
have to kneel at a Catholic wedding they
were going to write on the bottom of my
shoes help me right
I don't I didn't give a [__] oh we were
gonna ride on the bottom of Mary's shoes
you don't know
I mean we were going to throw bananas at
Gary when he walked down the aisle you
don't even know what we were going to do
but Gary had a lot of pressure on him we
were going to tase him as he walked down
this is the one moment even if he
rehearses you gotta write it down on a
paper even if it kills you if I do
anything I'm writing it on a paper and
I'm going to read it off the paper maybe
one of your poems even I'm working on
one it's kind of like free form
Stephanie I will love you when one tit
is big and even if the other one
shrivels like a Duncan munchkin I will
still love you till the day I die which
might be next month
[Laughter]
wow so that's poetry listen see that's a
guy to take advice from
foreign